how's it going bros my name is Pierre
ah welcome back to The Grudge our name
is Mika we're lost here in the abandoned
Hospital I mean I guess maybe we grow
handicaps wait we do this early I hate
them work all right Erica still walks
[ __ ] Lee slow
I mean sign keep calling her Erica I
think I'm gonna need renamed me Erica
whatever who cares I mean this is
bathroom and Erica oh yeah
I'm supposed to do like this I can't
Buddha said oh oh oh bro
someone has a lot of pubic hair holy
[ __ ] oh oh oh no let's get out of here
Oh what you doing in the men's room
that's boy added boy with a lot of pubic
hair all right me if I'm the farther
away Jesus Christ so nice it should work
properly now Erica you should be done it
can I open oh oh no I don't know the key
should I should i oh
oh we're good goddamn bra
oh okay let's [ __ ] that toilet I mean
not literally [ __ ] it but whatever all
right
someone told me in the comments what I'm
like I have to keep like this or at
least god I hate the week I'm not gonna
lie
I don't like the controls when it's
regular but when I use the Wii modes
like this it's so [ __ ] it's
ridiculous but whatever I know what
we're gonna do we're gonna go over here
look at the computers God am i lookin
for yours alright uh
firstly this is like a map and you're
supposed to go to the room that the
computer tells you to go
I'm a genius I thought I would i okay
300 won baby okay baby let's go we're
here now you need to exit and got a big
room huh it's right next to the men's
bathroom bathroom bathroom
alright whatever Erica erica all right
now I'm Mika okay fine take this way
okay good good good hey let's give me a
game where you walk we totally slow yes
yes maybe she has like a handicap thing
and I'm totally offending it right now
yeah she's funny I'm good yeah this is
what I get ah that is no explanation or
see why you're doing that though nude
soo hi I don't know I like I never get
this figured ah whatever
okay we're gonna go here trick ya trick
it in yet
right so the man's bet bathroom is here
so the big room and we're liking parties
over here I did it
[ __ ] okay well no bro bro bro okay
fine I don't care
Oh Oh book I hate that is that yet ah no
no ha ha anyone in here
someone oh god this is not good whoa bro
bro
put me back okay again hey hey mom is
that you
someone mess meeting okay I need to pick
up some item referred to here so TV I
don't need that look
oh it's good that it uh-oh oh god that
was close
ah ah no more TVs alright I need to find
something here how I miss a share how
about Manny I were looking everywhere
for you
nah nah okay again we're again alright
sick the room with a macerating boy or
girl
i I'm not even gonna talk about how
about much is here hi penny
there's supposed to be something here
don't let don't lie to me god damn
you're annoying me
said go to all the rooms and pick out
her son all right fine
there's nothing here let's get out let's
get the heck out of here okay yep
Erica erica i mean mica mica look at me
like me okay good idea
no come on you were just leaving we're
just leaving it's get a burr again wait
again
so that was a room 301 didn't get [ __ ]
but whatever all right okay Erica erica
erica erica mica whatever your name is
all right I'm pointing over here it's
gotta be left right why she answered
seriously she's changing that okay let's
go back to the computer and see if it
still says 301 are you still saying
three on one bra bra bra I still thing
for your mom you know what
well I'm so gonna die oh god I'm so I'm
gonna die oh I'm so screwed look at my
battery all right listen again it's
friggin Matt right next to the bedroom
bathroom been met whatever all right
wait wait wait wait wait wait my Erica
look at that
okay look at that not that god damn you
Erica we're gonna die we're gonna night
y'all fine it's your fault you know in
movies when you're like I shot your
fault that we die no it's definitely our
fault one room next to this and the next
room after day is it's not that one that
why I feel I don't understand
Erica do you want to die fine I'll go in
here 300 it says here one two three yeah
let's just check for funds can't be
something bad
all right again Oh
head on in here I'm pretty cozy I don't
think it is right okay let's go back
there's no I don't know why kind of turn
that out for humming hello anyone all
right let's go to 300 no whatever do
whatever I don't he Erica okay okay she
is okay
I'm your stray
it's a mass bathroom and this is 301 or
stephannie something emerged in 301 yep
a trio one alright let's go for it last
time it can't be the second time you
again it's impossible I think all right
hello heard someone masturbating
just curious in the roof maybe register
- floor maybe hello floor talk to me all
I can do is turn on the TV's I don't
know why fine I'm gonna keep turning on
TV show how much your share
let's got a room 301 I don't like this
game I know right wow that's fun but
Jesus Christ he walk so slow
yep let's go
alright it's you and me buddy
it's your me Erica let's go
[ __ ] hate that [ __ ] let's doing that
what is that I'm sad to you
I heard jumping Oh buddy buddy buddy
buddy no no no no it's not their night
please fix me see oh there's no one
there Oh bro ah ah ah bad right I live
ah ah no I look bad I owe you bad oh my
baby
then I this is I don't look at anyone
here
Wow and one in the bed now ah breaking
free from yeah ah alright
yep I'm just gonna turn left here Myka
Myka and I left you know left opposite
of right you know you know that you know
oh I can do this I can turn like this
why don't I don't tell me ah this is go
this is girls are done
what's a done with this place okay what
are we gonna call like an item someone's
I act like madam now Hey
okay
Erika Erika I hate you what we need to
do this
all right let's see if it change or
something I don't even know anymore
plagues changed place
don't say through your mom I'm gonna be
like I don't know if change we all on
again it's a spheal 5 in 306 that means
we'd made progress boys and girls let's
go to 305 and 306 I don't even know
where they are but make out you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're gonna look down with me
okay yep Myka Myka Myka Myka Myka Myka
Myka Myka yes
Myka good you're a good girl Myka now go
go you can do it do it for me
if not for your [ __ ] I don't even know
why I said that but Jesus Christ it go
we don't have a lot of time we just have
to do this it's you and me buddy all
right you're fine so the other one was
wait I think I'm walking in the wrong
direction actually I just said what is
this exit ah ah god I hate soccer it's
creepy as hell
I think I need to restart my computer
like usually it's
okay I actually should have spent time
and again I I'm gonna edit this video so
much
okay I was right
no or was I no other direction in the
end of the hallway okay let's do it does
this do it my arms getting tired ass
black this is stick the last rooms and
now we're I'm done
so done for this game for today at least
okay do you subscribe my arm okay
whatever I don't even care I care I was
just kidding I'm sorry okay [ __ ] it
let's go and get that thing I don't even
know what it is for 305 and 306 neither
it's a pubic hair again oh no oh no here
yeah I am not telling it I get it
aah aah aah aah aah stop please
Oh what is this TV what it oh Jesus
paint it shut up sorry
what is that
you
honestly I'm getting its how mr. Grouch
house I knew it I [ __ ] knew it
alright find his blooding switch gentle
man
hello fine
I don't even care wasting my damn time
oh no bro no bro
Oh pubic hair [ __ ] okay there we go
okay yeah pubic hair
alright let's taste beauty care Consuelo
hello miss pubic hair your damn pomp you
beginner anything I'm not gonna lie
alright let's just go alright say hello
to mr. pubic hair hey oh wow huh
actually good holy [ __ ]
alright oh are you your dad Oh kitty
hello kitty how you doing hello buddy no
are you going wait out okay I'm gonna
say it I can I'm gonna say it I can't so
good all right say it I can I can do it
I'm Pete if I push we're gonna go here
and then we're gonna be all like hey I
could what
okay how kitty come on kitty kitty cat
huh I was again I met ah ah ah nope
let's not go down okay
good huh how does tv-14 me ah ah ah
Jesus Christ
I had televisions alright fine how did
you it let's go to three of six ah Jesus
Christ
she just got I opened those doors in
slow mode energy he's that kind of
dressed doors all right three or six
buddy just go oh oh oh okay
three hours like buddy Anna hello Pierre
we care girl
Oh share mr. Shah don't think it working
it's where I kick how did you know just
be crap in it jam out